[Musique]
le temps christopherson après les orages
attention fortes pluies dans le sud est
oui en effet de fortes pluies météo
france qui maintient cinq départements
du sud-est en vigilance orange
rien n'est joué du côté de la maîtrise
avec patricia martin bonjour professeurs
bonjour c'est julien samuel hop autriche
et pourquoi pas tricher âge que j'ai
marqué pas qu'il s'est passé c'est pas
moi c'est une couche et une collègue de
france inter ça n'a pas du tout est à
noter de marc venez bruce pour le coup
c'est pas grave j'ai dit christophe
persuy mais c'était marc excusez moi mon
cher
je voulais continuer vous invite si je
vous dérange pas maintenant ça va vous
inquiétez pas une nouvelle tribune de
militaires a été publiée par le magazine
valeurs actuelles elle évoque elle aussi
de délitement de la france mais aussi le
risque d'une guerre civile
les signataires des militaires d'activé
et apter retraités mais nous n'avons pas
les noms ici ils sont restés anonymes
la ministre des armées et florence parly
a dénoncé une groupe une citation
politique pardon les mots et mahut x de
la crise se font une place parmi les
autres maux et mots ts du dictionnaire
cluster vaccinodromes asymptomatiques
tous ces termes et encore d'autres on va
pouvoir les utiliser dans nos prochaines
parties de scrabble windham et vous avez
oublier bien évidemment l'incontournable
de cette crise sanitaire coheed 19
la surprise de cette cliente d'un
supermarché de pennsylvanie aux etats
unis
à la vue de cette femme faisant ses
courses sous bulle intriguée elle a donc
suivi cachés dans les allées pour nous
montrer cette invention antico vide
étonnante une cabine intégral à
roulettes en plastique transparent le
casier dirigé grâce à deux trous pour
les bras les mains sont gantés mais pas
sûr qu'on puisse attraper tous les
produits en rayon avec ce système nous
sommes dans la bêtise artificielle et
non nous on est en présentiel non
présidentielle drôle d'ambiance à les
matinales radio ce matin mais aucun des
titulaires des matinales n'était là à la
place
rien que des remplaçants ainsi pas de
marc aurèle à france info
mais laurent sénéchal pas d'yves calvi
rtl mais jérôme fera sur europe 1 depuis
ce matin on n'arrête pas de lire cluster
l'émission qui aurait contaminé là
au moment où je vous parle on est en
direct et au moment où je vous parle il
ya personne parmi toutes les personnes
qui étaient sur ce plateau qui ont été
contaminés sur notre plateau en fait
c'est surtout la production de
l'émission qui a fait preuve de légèreté
selon nous un faux pas de tests pcr
heureux qui pour tous les invités pas de
tests rapides
un des participants m'a dit on s'est
tous dit en arrivant que ça ressemblait
un gros cluster cette émission que vous
avez été enjoint par le csa
effectivement d'inviter un représentant
des rations mensuelles dans le cadre de
la campagne et que j'aurais été en joie
mais je suis même pas vous aider
en disant cela on a un petit doute quand
même oui la fumée reda on n'a pas pu
mais les mêmes choses
[Musique]
les avocats c'est terrible à vous êtes
pire quand ya un peu de jalousie de
jalousie aux humains vous êtes jaloux
gilbert collard c'est en rêve c'est
d'être de marine le pen
ouais mais il le sera peut-être pas donc
de quoi pardon le ministre de la justice
de marine le pen si elle arrive au
pouvoir
en honorant je vais être ambassadeur de
france au vatican voilà oui bon nesat a
hissé sa ferme à 1 contre amos et les
lost l individualisme en canon ça s'est
massivement
quels sont les initiales jérôme vif et
jc comme jésus-christ il exactement est
marrant parce que mettez les bras comme
ça y'a quand même un petit terrain
jacques home sitter gilbert collard vous
êtes désireux je pourrais prier pour
vous et je me rappellerai toujours quand
on vous disait fermez-la el kabbaj
ben voyons ça m'a pas empêché de parler
vous voyez voilà on basculera sur des
sommes tirées qu'original est ce que
vous faites c'est jamie en france
gilbert fait gentil avec jean clair et
ce que j'ai d'abord suivi et jean pierre
elkabbach bam parce que sans eux mêmes
les fragiles ou gmail est fragile mais
vous avez dit que vous étiez quelqu'un
d'une origine assez riche
vous avez vous habitez 20,7 bon vous
habitez à vincennes j'ai réussi qui s'y
joue sa carte unique qu'est ce qui vous
a poussé sur une opération de police a
traité des policiers de bâtard alors que
les policiers vous ont à mon sens les
policiers de bâtard c'est fait et
condamné pour ça si mes peines étaient
postés sur c'était une blague et c'était
sur twitter d'accord c'est pas la
décadence de notre société ce qu'elle a
vécu l'occupation allemande pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale elle m'a dit
qu'elle ne supportait - mais moins de
gains notre notre situation actuelle que
et la seconde guerre mondiale avec
occupation le monde donc c'est quand
même il sait
harel croit elle on va pas tenir tout le
truc là dessus j'ai pas te raser les
policiers de la notoriété diane parent
dont la volonté d'être enfin d'être
l'auteur dans ce genre de propos vous
avez des policiers parce que c'est la
mode
bon vous avez un niveau d'un v6 lité qui
est qui et qui est étonnant quand on est
dans l'instant à s'écouler on se
respecte en messieurs dames 1 n'hésitez
pas à une petite pièce allez-y si jamais
mon tweet vous a plu c'est twitter qui
est en train de lancer une nouvelle
fonctionnalité qui s'appelle type jarre
que l'on peut traduire par boîte à
pourboire vous savez comme ces boîtes
que l'on retrouve fréquemment à côté des
caisses notamment les états unis que ce
soit dans les salons de coiffure les
restaurants ou encore toutes les
boutiques les américains ont pour
habitude de vider leurs poches pour
récompenser les employés et bien twitter
propose à peu près le même système mais
sur le net plus rien' les prothésistes
ongulaires
c'est un peu cliché mais toutes les
estiment qu'en fait ce que j'ai
rencontrés c'était débile au début je
sais pas sur quel pied danser je me suis
dit elle est prothésiste ongulaire
mais elle écrit bien d'être là rebond
correcteur automatique sepa nous
aimerions que vous puissiez vous
entraider les uns les autres annoncent
fièrement le réseau social est bien qui
encourage les utilisateurs à salut par
exemple l'anniversaire d'un abonné que
vous aimez bien en lui envoyant un petit
peu d'argent ou encore pour le féliciter
d'un tweet bien sentis qui aurait créé
le buzz n'allez pas croire que le masque
se lance dans le stand-up
le milliardaire a néanmoins choisi le
biais de l'humour pour révélé être
atteint du syndrome d'asperger
réinventer la voiture électrique et j'en
vois des gens sur la planète mars à bord
d'une fusée
vous pensiez vraiment que j'étais un
gars détendue est normal je veux pas
rester comme ça tout est dit mais je
vais me reprendre en main à m tu croises
un épi des petits qui convient la raison
essentielle pour laquelle on mort c'est
parce qu'on vit on m'a répondu non
vivres a répondu ça dépend de nous c'est
la vérité oui mais à condition ça dépend
de nous si ça dépend du voisin